[Música]
el estado estadounidense de Georgia está
a horas de que inicie la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones de medio mandato en la
que se enfrentan el demócrata Rafael
Warner y el republicano herschel Walker
por un último escaño en el senado Pese a
que la cámara alta ya está en control de
los demócratas con 50 sillas ganaron a
más se considera clave Tenemos reporte
ascendió a 34 el número de víctimas
mortales tras un deslizamiento de tierra
en el occidente de Colombia debido a las
fuertes y continuas lluvias que golpean
al país el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
declaró la alerta Roja en todo el
territorio nacional pues se espera que
les precipitaciones se mantengan al
menos hasta febrero
tras la goleada 4-1 de Brasil a Corea
del Sur El lunes y la eliminación de
Japón a manos de Croacia Este martes se
juega la última fecha de los octavos de
final en el mundial de fútbol Marruecos
se enfrenta a España y Portugal a Suiza
por los últimos dos cupos a los cuartos
de final ampliamos desde Qatar
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundial de qatarso y
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Estados
Unidos porque este martes se realiza en
Georgia la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones de medio mandato para definir
Quién será el senador por ese estado
estadounidense la contienda está entre
El republicano herschel Walker y el
demócrata Rafael guarnok el control del
senado ya está en manos de los
demócratas con 50 escaños y el voto de
la vicepresidenta camela Harris que
Define cuando hay empate sin embargo
ganar este asiento se ha convertido en
una importante cuestión para Joe biden y
su partido previamente conversamos con
Cristóbal Vázquez que nos contó la
importancia de esa silla para los
demócratas la importancia que tienen
estas elecciones acá en Georgia es que
si los demócratas aseguran 51 votos en
el senado dejan de depender de un
senador demócrata que ha votado en los
últimos proyectos legislativos a favor
de los republicanos entonces tener 51
pues saltaría y le daría Independencia
al partido demócrata para poder avanzar
en su agenda al menos en el senado el
segundo punto importante por la cual
esta elección está en la mira de muchos
medios internacionales y de muchos
actores políticos en Estados Unidos es
que kamala Harris dejaría de tener que
ir siempre al congreso a dar su voto de
desempate y podría entonces enfocarse
más en su proyecto político sobre todo
de Cara a la campaña de reelección del
2024 y en un tercer punto Porque estos
51 votos de mayoría que tendrían los
demócratas pues le darían poder en las
comisiones del senado para avanzar mucho
más rápido los proyectos legislativos
además confirmaría que pues ya Georgia
que antes era un estado rojo ya es un
estado péndulo un estado que ya en las
elecciones más importantes del país
puede votar demócrata como también
republicano
el gobierno de Joe biden extendió otros
18 meses el estatus de protección
temporal para ciudadanos haitianos
previamente el programa vencía el 4 de
Febrero de 2023 y ahora estará vigente
hasta agosto de 2024 así lo comunicó al
departamento de seguridad nacional en un
comunicado en el que se especifica que
los haitianos que hayan ingresado al
territorio estadounidense después del
seis de noviembre de 2022 de forma
irregular no son elegibles para este
estatus y Por tanto se exponen a hacer
deportados la medida protege de la
deportación y da acceso a permisos de
trabajo a unas 155 mil personas
vamos ahora hasta Colombia porque un
deslizamiento de tierra en una carretera
del departamento de risaralda en el
occidente del país deja un saldo de al
menos 34 personas muertas según
informaron las autoridades las labores
de búsqueda terminaron además declararon
la alerta máxima por la fuerte temporada
de lluvias que experimenta el país
Andrés triviño nos cuenta más
la imparable temporada de lluvias en
Colombia sigue cobrando vidas un
deslizamiento de tierra en el
departamento colombiano de risaralda
mató a decenas de personas después que
el autobús en el que se desplazaban
quedara sepultado el bus se encontraba
sepultado a unos dos metros bajo tierra
Así mismo llevaba un total de 37
personas incluido el conductor y su
ayudante de las cuales fallecieron 34
entre los cuales se encuentran ocho
menores al parecer otros vehículos
particulares también quedaron bajo
tierra El deslizamiento se produjo el
domingo en una vía que comunica al
centro con el occidente del país según
las autoridades el terreno se encontraba
fuertemente afectado luego de varios
días de lluvias lo cual complicó las
labores de rescate que ya terminaron
debido a que se trata de una zona
montañosa y un terreno inestable desde
agosto del 2020 Colombia ha sufrido los
estragos del fenómeno de la niña dejando
tras su paso más del 60% de los
municipios afectados los pronósticos
estiman que el fen se mantendrá hasta
por lo menos febrero del 2023
queremos declarar nuestra alerta máxima
en todo el territorio por esta ola
invernal que ha traído tanto daño
material y también en vidas como la que
acaba de ocurrir la unidad nacional para
la gestión del riesgo de desastres instó
a los habitantes de la zona a evacuar
sus hogares ya que se podrían presentar
nuevos deslizamientos mientras las
lluvias siguen afectando todo el país
vamos Argentina en donde el presidente
Alberto Fernández anunció que pedirá a
la justicia una investigación contra un
grupo de empresarios jueces Fiscales y
exfuncionarios por presuntamente hacer
parte de una trama de corrupción el
mandatario argentino hizo referencia a
un supuesto viaje en un avión privado a
la localidad del Lago escondido en la
Patagonia a la mansión de Joe Luis una
acaudalado Hombre de negocios británico
los detalles los tienen natalio cosoy
corresponsal de France 24 en Buenos
Aires
quienes aparecen en la filtraciones
hablan de espionaje ilegal de una
operación en su contra del otro lado lo
señalan especialmente a los funcionarios
del poder judicial de haber desarrollado
una actividad incompatible con sus
funciones esa reunión cerca de Bariloche
en lado escondido una en una propiedad
del Magnate Joe Luis un hombre cercano
al ex presidente Mauricio macri la
realidad es que no está claro En qué
consistió ese encuentro y los
protagonistas tampoco han salido a
explicar
exactamente de qué se trató Y eso Abre a
suspicacias bueno el presidente Alberto
Fernández en su declaración pública en
Cadena Nacional habló de eso habló de
que le solicitó al ministro de Justicia
que avanzara con una acusación con una
denuncia a los protagonistas de este
encuentro y de la filtraciones hay que
ver hacia qué lado va Lo cierto es que
hay que recordar que en Argentina el
poder judicial tiene muy mala imagen y
hay algo más Esto se está dando en el
contexto en el que este martes se
conocerá la sentencia potencial puede
ser absolutoria o condenatoria de la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner en la causa vialidad en la que
los acusados están investigados por
asociación ilícita y defraudación al
estado y esta noticia no hace más que
enrarecer aún más el clima en este
momento en Argentina
noticias deportivas la penúltima jornada
de octavos de final en el mundial de
fútbol estuvo marcada por la goleada 4-1
de Brasil ante Corea del Sur La
canarinha y Croacia se llevaron dos de
los cuatro cupos para los cuartos de
final Este martes se enfrentan Marruecos
y España y Portugal contra Suiza desde
doha Juan pupiales enviado especial de
France 24 nos amplió
mucho mejor con Neymar victoria de la
canareña por 4 a 1 contra Corea del Sur
en un encuentro en el que de nuevo Vimos
a la Brasil más ofensiva con esos cuatro
delanteros uno de ellos uno que no había
marcado vinicius Junior Gabriela lata al
minuto 7 y para el minuto 13 la
canarinha ya ganaba con 2 a 0 esta vez
lo hizo otro jugador otro delantero
quien no había marcado en ese certamen
Neymar quien volvió y marcó desde el
punto de penalti para conseguir así su
tercer tanto en una copa mundo después
llegó el tanto de Richard y finalmente
el tanto de Lucas paqueta todo esto en
la primera parte una primera parte en
donde Eso sí cubría del sur exigió
Allison con un disparo que exigió una
enorme atajada por parte de git San Juan
para que se exhibiera el portero de la
selección brasileña para la segunda
parte de ese premio de esa intensidad
ofensiva que demostró por momentos Corea
del Sur tuvo su premio con el gol de
Swan Hum en línea general es una Brasil
muy ofensiva y con la buena noticia de
que Neymar jugó 80 minutos que está
completamente recuperado de esa lesión
en su tobillo derecho el rival de la
canarinha será Croacia que se impuso
Japón en un duelo completamente distinto
un duelo muy igualado Los japoneses que
se adelantaron al minuto 43 con un tanto
de ella y tuvo que esperar Croacia hasta
la segunda parte para poner el uno a uno
obra de Iván persis así Se llegó hasta
los tiros de penalti que definen lo que
fue este encuentro en la tanda de
penaltis el portero de los croatas
dominical se impuso como el gran héroe
después de atajar hasta tres tiros de
penalti Victoria para los croatas en
esta tanda por 3 a 1 y con su portero
como gran figura croatas y brasileños
que se me dieran en cuartos de final
aquí en Qatar 2022 el próximo viernes
finalizamos en Río de Janeiro donde el
icónico Cristo Redentor se vistió de
verde y amarillo para celebrar la
victoria de la verde amarela la
selección nacional logró su Victoria con
goles de vinicios Junior richarlison y
Lucas paquetá además un penalti de
Neymar con estas imágenes llegamos al
final de nuestra emisión quédense con
nosotros que volvemos en breve
[Música]